[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
June 27th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
a series of experiments has shown that
although consumers have voiced
displeasure over taxes and fees tacked
onto prices in many cases they have no
problem paying them Wall Street Journal
numbers columnist Josh zumbrun joins us
with more so Josh in your column you
write that economists call the addition
of taxes and fees drip pricing why do
they call it that drip pricing is the
term that it kind of refers to the idea
that you see this initial price and as
you go through the purchasing process
things are dripped onto it you know you
get a fee a service charge an amenity
fee whatever it might be you see these
in obviously a lot of different
Industries applied in a lot of different
ways but the basic effect is that over
time as you go through the process of
purchasing the product you end up with a
much higher price at the end than you
started with now how is this different
from tipping that's often added on to
prices the common thing obviously is
that you end up paying more than you
expect but there's two key differences I
mean the one is that the drip pricing is
really not not optional in most cases
it's something that you have to pay you
know if you want to buy those concert
tickets if you want to buy that plane
ticket whatever you have to pay those
fees whereas the Tipping is it's
optional right I mean you know even at a
restaurant if you want to leave a zero
percent tip you can so one is the
optionality two is the kind of emotional
part of it that's involved right I mean
the reason you don't leave a zero
percent tip is that it's very rude all
right so back to taxes and fees you
discuss a series of experiments that
focus on the psychology of consumers
when facing tact on fees in one test
retailers included taxes and fees on a
product's price tag pretty much to
eliminate any surprise how do consumers
respond right so people hate hidden fees
I mean I don't think there's any
question about that right this is a very
annoying practice but here's the kind of
problem from the perspective of
retailers and companies is that when you
try to be transparent about the prices
consumers actually the way they act and
the way they then purchase is they
really hate that so one of the
experiments this is kind of a famous
experiment in economics they went to a
grocery store and they said hey can we
just put the full price on a handful of
items and the grocery store said this is
going to be a disaster we don't really
want you to do this to very many items
but you can do it on a few and we'll see
what happens and so they just took the
price tags on items like hair brushes
and like a few personal items that
weren't even big Sellers and they made
the price tag say here's the price 5.99
after tax this is going to be 650.
that's the extent of the change they did
it on all the hair brushes right and the
entire category of hair brushes people
bought about 10 percent less hair
brushes at the grocery store when they
had to see what the full price was and
they surveyed people afterwards and they
said do you know what sales tax is and
they did the people knew what the sales
tax was and they said did you know sales
tax applied to hair brushes yes we did
but when people were actually presented
with that information as they walked
through the aisles it made them not want
to buy hair brushes anymore so you have
this problem where if the hairbrush
industry agreed hey we want to always
include our full prices people would buy
less hair brushes than they would buy
other stuff at the grocery store it's a
really powerful effect that people
reject items when they see that full
price now several years ago the ticket
reseller StubHub responded to how
consumers felt about tact on costs and
they did away with all hidden fees how
did that affect business they did a big
marketing campaign saying no more hidden
fees what you see is what you pay the
first ticket price you see is going to
be what you get at the end so they
thought we can really stand out and earn
a lot of trust by not doing any hidden
fees and so for a couple years they
tried this and consumers in practice
hated it not only did they buy far less
tickets but they actually would buy not
as good tickets too so what what StubHub
eventually found is that when you do the
hidden fees people go to this site and
they see these initial prices they know
these additional fees are coming but
they still kind of get in their head
like oh I could buy much better seats so
they pick much better seats they go
through the process they get the final
price it's much higher than that initial
price so they not only buy more tickets
but they buy better tickets when you use
the hidden fees and stubhub's business
got so hurt by the transparency their
sales were down about 20 percent it was
a huge hit and they had to abandon their
effort to be transparent because they
were just getting clobbered by consumers
so what can consumers do to ensure
they're actually getting the lowest
price one of the most important
takeaways is that it would be helpful if
consumers were a little bit more willing
to start the process over when they got
to the end and they ended up with
something that's much more expensive one
of the things that happens is people
complete their shopping process and it's
much more expensive than they thought
and they just say ah you know it's
probably going to be like that
everywhere and I've decided I really
want this concert ticket I've decided I
really want to order this item whatever
it may be and they're not willing to
stop and start over and go back and
check if other places actually have
better rates and so I mean there's two
problems that come because people don't
restart the search I mean one is that
they don't go out there and identify the
better price two is that companies don't
get penalized for having done a huge
amount of drip pricing if consumers
would get to the end of the process and
reject it you know that would start
showing up in companies data and they
would say hey this is a practice that
isn't working but that's not what
companies see they don't see people
rejecting drip pricing in large numbers
and in fact they see people rejecting
transparent pricing in large numbers and
so it makes it very very difficult for
companies to offer people the
transparent pricing that they think they
want that's Wall Street Journal
columnist Josh zumbrun and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you